après avoir passé onze ans ici on sent
comme un à quelques jours de partir
on sent fébrile mais en même temps j'ai
la conviction d'avoir fait un peu le
tour du jardin chez sentiment du devoir
accompli
j'ai essayé je les fait j'ai mis mon
coeur s'entamer traite de travail commun
le fou j'ai adoré ça mais là je
commençais à croire que cet instant pour
moi se retrouve très bientôt de nombreux
députés ne remettront plus les pieds à
l'assemblée nationale parce qu'ils ont
choisi de mettre fin à leur carrière
politique au moins un sur cinq en fait
c'est le cas du député péquiste
alexandre cloutier
[Musique]
ces mesures
la politique ça va au bout
à 200km sûr à 100 qu'il ya des chances
que tu commences à cyril laparre le plus
beau moment politique depuis onze ans ça
a été quoi très très très très très
sincèrement ce sont les deux courses au
leadership
pourquoi parce que c'est le moment qui
peut être exprimé complètement l'hébreu
mans sans aucune contrainte que la dire
ce que je pense qu'il est tant mieux
pour le québec mais je voulais surtout
porté avec françois gendron dans la
première course au leadership qui
m'avait appui puis ce test extrêmement
significatif pour moi
attention qu'il ya pu y avoir ou qu'il
ya encore avec jean françois lisée le
chef du parti québécois sur les
questions d'identité par exemple qu'est
ce que vous en pensez qu'il ya personne
qui a le monopole de la vérité sur des
enjeux aussi complexe pour les traiter
avec beaucoup de sérieux et de
préférence sans fin dont pas une section
ces engins le moment le plus laid c'est
premièrement toutes les histoires de
jeux de coulisses c'est ce qui m'a miné
le plus mais ça fait partie de la
politique
enfin partis politiques mais beaucoup
trop puisque orange france abrite il
devrait devenir ou à l'essence et à 10
par des dossiers aux portes des écoles
depuis quand est troisième à trois des
quatre rien à dire ça à exiger quoi de
votre famille
la politique faut vraiment que les
conjoints conjointe fasse partie de
cette aventure un sentiment de
culpabilité aussi qui finit par
s'installer quand deux jeunes enfants la
maison pour ce genre de conte 1er mai ça
prend des motifs qui sont fondamentaux
alors après le travail c'était vrai ou
si la vie parlementaire d'avoir autre
chose que la politique dans la vie vous
si le vélo je pense que pour survivre la
pression d'après le site vaut mieux
avoir quelques échappatoires avec tout
ce qui se passe en d'âge bloc québécois
ce que vous avez des doutes parfois sur
la question souveraine
non parce que c'est pas ponctuelle dans
c'est un longue marche puis c'est une
marche qui s'apprend la vitesse qu'un
peuple québécois soient bien la prendre
allez vous revenir en politique on verra
si un jour je crois les individus je
crois et mon mental je crois une
occasion mais peut-être que je dois
saisir innombrables